BORCHES BRADFORD CABALLERO
PROTESTING DALLY DODD TORONTO
AIKMAN GLAZER GONZALEZ GROSS
HERTZBERG WITHOUT HER TADO JONES
CAM LONGER LAYERED LABOR THE MON
THE CHOIR MELINDA'S MAN. NEWMAN
NIELSEN A TROUBLED PAM FORTUNE
TINO OFF RUBIO SKINNER TURN ON
BOURKE WHITE CASPI WINNER WELL.
THANK YOU MA'AM SECRETARY A
QUORUM IS PRESIDENT WITH THE
MEMBERS AND OUR GUESTS BEYOND
THE REAL IN THE GALLERY PLEASE
RISE WILL BE LED IN PRAYER THIS
AFTERNOON BY SENATOR RUBIO AFTER
WHICH PLEASE REMAIN STANDING
WILL BE LED IN THE PLEDGE OF
ALLEGIANCE. TO THE FLAG
QUESTION- CELLO BOW. SENATOR
RUBIO THANK YOU. GRACIOUS GOD
AND THE WOMAN AT THE HEBREW AND
CHRISTIAN SCRIPTURES YOU HAVE
GIVEN A STRONG MODELS FOR LIFE
AND FAITH. SARAH LAUGHED AT THE
THOUGHT OF BECOMING A MOTHER IN
HER OLD AGE GRANT US
APPRECIATION FOR THE SURPRISES
OF YOUR GRACE. DEBORAH AND
JUDITH WERE FEARLESS IN FACING
THE ENEMIES OF THEIR PEOPLE GIVE
US COURAGE BEFORE WHATEVER
THREATENS US. ROUTE PROVED THE
VALUE OF RELATIONSHIPS AND
FIDELITY MAY WE BE LOYAL TO OUR
FRIENDS AND FAITHFULTO OUR
COMMITMENTS. ESTHER ENDANGERED
HERSELF FOR THE SAKE OF HER
PEOPLE GIVE US AND SHARE IN HER
DIGNITY AND DEVOTION. IMAC DYLAN
TESTIFIED TO HER EXPERIENCE OF
JESUS MAY WE SPEAK OUR TRUTH IN
THE FACE OF DERISION. PHOEBE
OFFERS SECRET SERVICE TO THOSE
IN POWER MAY WE RESPOND TO THE
NEEDS OF OTHERS REGARDLESS OF
THEIR STATUS. AND MARY THE
MOTHER OF JESUS PONDERS COSTS
MYSTERIES IN HER HEART MAYBE
LISTEN ATTENTIVELY TO GOD'S
UNIQUE CALL TO EACH OF US MAY WE
FIND INSPIRATION IN THE LIVES OF
THESE WOMEN. A MAN. MEMBERS
PLEASE JOIN ME IN THE FLAT AND
SAY THE PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE. HI
MY DILIGENCE TO THE FLAG. ALL.
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS MESSAGES
FROM THE GOVERNOR WILL BE DEEMED
READ MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY
WILL BE DEEMED READ REPORTS OF
COMMITTEE WILL BE DEEMED RED AND
AMENDMENTS ADOPTED MEMBERS WERE
MOVING TO MOTIONS RESOLUTIONS
AND NOTICES I WOULD LIKE TO
PRESENT A RECOGNIZED META PRO
TEM SENATOR ATKINS THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT I WOULD REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO TAKE UP
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
EIGHTY TWO WITHOUT REFERENCE TO
COMMITTEE OR FILE. IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO USING UNANIMOUS
CONSENT. SEEING AND HEARING NONE. MRS MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION EIGHTY TWO BY SENATOR
ATKINS RELATIVE TO THE ADOPTION
OF THE CURRENT RULES OF THE
SENATE AND ASSEMBLY FOR THE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
REGULAR SESSIONS. CENTER ACTIONS
. MADAM PRESIDENT THANK YOU-
COLLEAGUES. S. C. R. EIGHTY TWO
WILL ADOPT THE JOINT RULES FOR
THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
SESSION. TRADITIONALLY THE TWO
HOUSES UP JOINT RULES TO
STANDARDIZE MANY PROCESSES
BETWEEN OUR TWO HOUSES. DURING
SOME SESSIONS THE TWO HOUSES
DON'T REACH AN AGREEMENT AND WE
OPERATE USING CUSTOM AND
PRACTICE. BUT IT IS THE BEST
PRACTICE TO ADOPT NEW JOINT
RULES WITH SOME REGULARITY. THE
RULES IN S. C. R. EIGHTY TO R.
SENSUALLY THE SAME IN MOST
RESPECTS AS PASSED SENATE RULES
AND TRADITIONS. BUT AMONG THE
CHANGES TO THE JOINT RULES ARE
USING GENDER NEUTRAL
TERMINOLOGY. CLARIFYING THAT
BILL HEARINGS CAN BE HELD IN
THE- STREET BUILDING NOT JUST
THE CAPITAL. MODERNIZING OUR
BUDGET CONFERENCE COMMITTEE
PROCESS TO ALLOW GREATER
TRANSPARENCY AND INPUT.
CODIFYING OUR LEGISLATIVE
DEADLINES THERE ARE SOME OTHER
MINOR CHANGES TO BE CONSISTENT
WITH OUR SENATE RULES. SO I
WOULD ASK FOR YOUR I. VOTE.
THANK YOU MADAM- PROTEST MEMBERS
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. OH
SORRY SENATOR NELSON AND MATTER
PRESENT LATE MARTIN AND I
COULDN'T SEE IT. SENATOR NELSON
AND THEN SENATOR WILK. META
PRESENTATIONS ON THE SENATE THIS
IS A RARE OCCASION FOR ME BUT I
WILL OPPOSE THESE RULE CHANGES.
IN MANY WAYS OVER THE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS. WE HAVE SEEN
DELIBERATE ACTIONS OF THE
LEGISLATURE TO DIMINISH PUBLIC
INPUT IN THE PROCESS. ALTHOUGH
MOST EGREGIOUS IS THE PUBLIC
COMMENT WHICH IS VIRTUALLY A
JOKE. PEOPLE GET THE CALL IN AND
SAY I'M JANE I LIKE IT- BILL AND
I DON'T THAT'S NOT PUBLIC INPUT
. MANY OTHER THINGS AS WELL. I'M
PLEASED THAT WE ARE GOING TO
HAVE A CONFERENCE COMMITTEE THIS
YEAR WE CAN HIT ROCK BOTTOM BUT
DIDN'T EVEN HAVE A CONFERENCE
COMMITTEE BEFORE FOR A YEAR TO.
BUT I THINK IT'S UNWIELDY. I
DON'T NECESSARILY THINK IT'S
GOING TO BE HELPFUL. IT SHOULD
BE CONFINED TO THE DIFFERENCES.
IN THE TWO SEPARATE VERSIONS OF
THE BUDGET. NOT NECESSARILY A
FREE FOR ALL. EVEN NASH
STRUCTURALLY HOW THE BUILDING
WORKS NOW. THE CITIZENS HAVE
LESSER INPUT. INDEED THIS
INSTITUTION. I THINK SOME OF IT
MAY WELL BE BY DESIGN I DO NOT
ACCUSE NOT NECESSARILY THESE
RULES ARE SUCH AN EXERCISE. BUT
TO STEP IN THE WRONG DIRECTION.
THEN JUST STEP THAT MAKES THE
SENATE. MUCH MORE CAN. THE
CONDUCT AN OPERATION OF THE
ASSEMBLY. AND THAT'S BEEN A
SIGNIFICANT BOON OVER THE
DECADES IN THIS INSTITUTION.
WE'VE HAD SENATE RULES WITHOUT
ASSEMBLY RULES. WE HAVE
SOMETHING HERE THOUGH THAT'S
DIFFERENT THAT'S BEEN SENATORIAL
COURTESY. THAT'S BEEN SOMEWHAT
PRESERVED. MY LAST DAY HERE I
MAY SAY A WORD ABOUT THIS AGAIN
. I WAS HERE TWELVE YEARS AND
GONE EIGHTEEN AND I CAME BACK
AND PEOPLE SAY JIM WHAT'S
DIFFERENT. WELL I SAID IT'S
SOCIETAL IT IS NOT JUST. IN THE
LEGISLATURE. BUT RESPECT FOR
EACH OTHER AND RESPECT FOR THE
INSTITUTION AND ITS RULES HAVE
GREATLY DIMINISHED. I BEMOAN
THAT AND IN PART BECAUSE OF THAT
I WILL VOTE NO ON THESE RULES.
THANK YOU SENATOR NELSON SENATOR
WILK I DO APOLOGIZE BUT YOUR
MICROPHONE WAS RIGHT IN THE DARK
PART OF YOUR SUIT AND I CANNOT
SEE YOU BUT PLEASE PROCEED.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
ACTUALLY HAVE A QUESTION FOR THE
AUTHOR. MY NUMBER TEN WHEN YOU
TAKE A QUESTION YES PLEASE
PROCEED. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT I'M JUST INTERESTED ON
FIFTEEN MONTHS INTO THE SESSION
WHY WE HAVE TO WAR FOR THIS TO
THE FLOOR I'M NOT I I'D LIKE TO
KNOW. THE THINKING OF WHY WE'RE
NOT GOING TO THE REGULAR PROCESS
MEMBER TIM. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT. IT HAS BEEN OUR
DESIRE TO GET THE JOINT RULES-
DONE OF COURSE BEFORE NOW- IT'S
A NEGOTIATION WITH THE ASSEMBLY
THERE WERE SOME OUTSTANDING
ISSUES. ARE THAT WE WERE TRYING
TO WORK WITH HIM IN TERMS OF
COMMITTEE SELECTIONS WHO CHAIRS
WHAT COMMITTEE THE ASSEMBLY OR
THE- SENATE. WE NEGOTIATED- AT
SOME POINT- WE REALIZE THAT WE
SHOULD HAVE THE RULES IN PLACE
WHILE WE DO HAVE SENATE RULES-
WE NOW HAVE A SECOND BUILDING-
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT ARE. THE
ASSEMBLY WANTED TO MAKE SURE
THAT WERE WE AGREED ON IN THE
JOINT RULES WAS FOR EXAMPLE.
HOLDING HEARINGS IN THE- STREET
BUILDING SO- THERE WAS NO EFFORT
NOT TO GET THEM DONE THERE WAS A
CONTINUED EFFORT TO CONTINUE TO
NEGOTIATE ON SOME ITEMS THAT WE
FELT ARE I FELT. AND WE FELT
WOULD GIVE THE SENATE- MAYBE-
I'M SURE IT DIPLOMATICALLY LET
ME SAY THAT WE WOULD HAVE OUR
BALANCE IN TERMS OF THOSE SORTS
OF THINGS IF YOU SERVE ON THE
RULES COMMITTEE. AND A NUMBER OF
MEMBERS IN THIS HOUSE SERVE ON
THE JOINT RULES COMMITTEE YOU
KNOW THE KINDS OF ISSUES THAT WE
ACTUALLY NEGOTIATE BETWEEN THE
HOUSES. AND SO THE ADDITIONAL
TIME WE TOOK ASIDE FROM THE FACT
THAT WE ARE IN A PANDEMIC AND WE
PASSED RULS OF THE SENATE. THAT
REFLECTED SOME EMERGENCY
MEASURES THAT WE NEEDED TO TAKE
AND BE ABLE TO PIVOT AND MEET
THE NEEDS OF THE SENATE. WE
REALLY WANTED TO PUSH AND TRY TO
GET SOME MORE AGREEMENTS WITH
THE ASSEMBLY ON OTHER THINGS BUT
AT THIS POINT- IT WOULD BE GOOD
FOR US TO HAVE JOINT RULES SO.
WE DIDN'T RUSH BECAUSE WE WERE
TRYING TO GET MORE THINGS DONE
BUT WE WERE ALSO IN THE MIDST OF
A PANDEMIC AND WE STILL ARE WE
WILL SEE HOW. WE CONTINUE TO
FARE. ON AS WE GO INTO THE NEXT
MONTH AS THESE CHANGES HAVE
HAPPENED SO. THANK YOU MADAM PRO
TEM SENATOR WILK I THANK YOU ON
MY OWN TIME. NEVER REALLY ANSWER
THE QUESTION WHY WERE WORKING
IT- WHEN WE'VE BEEN FIFTEEN
MONTHS INTO THIS HI HAVING SAID
THAT I WOULD SAY- LOG. OBVIOUSLY
A LOT OF THESE THINGS WE NEED TO
BE UPDATED HAVE NOPE HAVE
ABSOLUTELY NO PROBLEM WITH THAT
WHY DO YOU HAVE A PROBLEM
HOWEVER IS I HAVE SERVED AS VICE
CHAIR OF RULES IN THE ASSEMBLY
IN VICE CHAIR OF RULES IN THE
SENATE. IN THE IN THE ASSEMBLY
IT'S A COMPLETE JOKE ALL THE
POWER IS IN THE SPEAKER'S OFFICE
AND THERE'S NO CLAPPER
COLLABORATIVE EFFORT AT ALL ONE
OF THINGS THAT I VALUE ABOUT
THIS AND IT IS WORKING
COLLABORATIVE LEE AND THE RULES
COMMITTEE IN MY TIME THERE I
REALLY ENJOYED IT. FELT LIKE THE
MINORITY HAD INPUT- THIS IS
TAKING A LOT OF PROVISIONS AND
PUTTING IT IN THE OFFICE OF THE
PROTEST I VERY MUCH LIKE A
RESPECT OUR CURRENT PRO TEM BUT
SHE'S NOT GOING TO ALWAYS BE PRO
TEM. I HAVE A REAL CONCERNED
ABOUT THAT SO I WOULD ENCOURAGE
I ENCOURAGE ALL OF YOU BUT AT
LEAST BY MEMBERS TO VOTE NO ON
THE RULE CHANGES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR WELL. SIR EDMUND.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. JENNIFER I
JUST BROUGHT RISE IN SUPPORT-
AND JUST A BIASING CALLING. FROM
TO HEMA- THIS IS MY FIRST TIME
IN THE LEGISLATURE DESPITE BEING
HERE FOR. MY TENTH YEAR NOW
ELEVEN SOMETHING. UP IT'S MY
FIRST TIME SERVING ON THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE. AND I CAN TELL YOU
THE AMOUNT OF PUBLIC COMMENTS
THAT COME IN WITH OUR OUR NEW.
WAY OF DOING THAT I THINK
EXPANDS THE REACH. TO THE PUBLIC
AND WE'RE IN WAYS THAT WE NEVER
DREAMED OF BEFORE I KNOW. I WAS
LUCKY ENOUGH TO SPEND MY
BIRTHDAY AND BUDGET COMMITTEE
THIS LAST THURSDAY. AND OVER TWO
HUNDRED PEOPLE CALLED TO WISH ME
A HAPPY BIRTHDAY. DURING A
PUBLIC COMMENT SO I CAN JUST
WANT TO JUST WANT TO. INSURE
THAT THE PUBLIC'S MIND THE
PUBLIC COMMENTS AND DO WORK AND
I THINK PEOPLE WOULD LIKE TO BE
ABLE TO USE OUR TELEPHONIC
SYSTEMS. LONG AFTER. WE ARE WE
ARE ALL BACK. AND WITH OUR OUR
LOVELY SMILING FACES AS A WAY.
TO EXPAND THE AMOUNT OF PUBLIC
COMMENT INTO OUR PROCESS THANK
YOU. THE USER EDMUNDSON
HERTZBERG. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT I HAVE A- I HAVE HAD
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SERVE IN MANY
OF THESE VARIOUS CAPACITIES AND
HAVE HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO GO
SHE- THESE TYPES OF JOINT RULES
IN THE PAST AND THE CHALLENGES
FACING THE HOUSES. IS QUITE
DELICATE AND- I CURRENTLY SERVE
AT THE PLEASURE OF THE PRO TEM
IS THE VICE CHAIR REPRESENTING
THE SENATE ON THE JOINT RULES
COMMITTEE. AND I JUST WANTED TO
ADD MY VOICE. TO THE
THOUGHTFULNESS AND I KNOW
THERE'S OFTEN ISSUES BACK AND
FORTH BUT AGAIN THESE ARE HARD
THINGS TO DO AND I THINK THAT
THE PRO TEM AND THE TEAM HAS
REALLY STRUCK AN INTELLIGENT
BALANCE UNDER THE CIRCUMSTANCES
AND I STAND IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE SHOW- ESSERE. THANK YOU
SENATOR HERTZBERG MEMBERS
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SENATOR WIENER I THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT I TO RISE IN SUPPORT
OF THESE RULES AND I SEE THIS
THERE ARE SOME GOOD
MODERNIZATION CHANGES IN HIS
ROLES AS A SENATOR FROM STOCKTON
MENTION ANOTHER ONE- IS THE
ABILITY TO BE MUCH MORE NIMBLE
WHEN A MEMBER IS OUT FOR EXAMPLE
SEX- NOT BEING SHORT HANDED ON A
COMMITTEE AND MAKING SURE THAT
WE CAN PUT THE POTEMKIN PUT A
REPLACEMENT MEMBER ON THAT
COMMITTEE- WHEN I FIRST JOINED
THE CENTER I WAS TOLD BY MY
SUPERSTAR. THAT IF YOU HAVE A
BUILDING FOR LET'S SAY A FIVE
PERSON COMMITTEE AND SOMEONE AT
THE LAST MINUTE GET SACKED THIS
IS GOING TO BE A VACANCY ON THAT
COMMITTEE AND YOUR BILL MIGHT
DIE FOR BECAUSE WE'RE SHORT ONE
MEMBER ON A SMALL COMMITTEE I
ALWAYS THOUGHT THAT WAS REALLY
PROBLEMATIC BECAUSE WE UNLIKE
THE ASSEMBLY WE HAD A VERY MORE
ALIVE OR PROCESS TO ACTUALLY
REPLACE A MEMBER BURLY
PARTICULARLY WHICH WOULD BE
IMPOSSIBLE IF I GET SICK AT THE
LAST MINUTE. AND THIS IS OUR
LEADER PRO TEM THE ABILITY TO
MAKE SURE THESE COMMITTEES ARE
FULLY FUNCTIONAL AND FULLY
STAFFED AND I'M GRATEFUL FOR
THAT CHANGE OCCURS AND I VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR WIENER CENTER
CORTESE. OF THANK YOU MAYOR OF.
MADAM I WANTED TO CHIME IN- IN
AGREE. WITH MY COLLEAGUE FROM
SAN FRANCISCO AND I'VE BEEN
HERE- JUST A SHORT THIRTEEN
MONTHS AND I'VE ALREADY HAD AT
LEAST TWO OCCASIONS TO. TO
PERSONALLY EXPERIENCE THE NEED.
FOR THE- FOR A PRO TEM TO BE
ABLE TO- TO APPOINT. SOMEBODY ON
A MOMENT'S NOTICE- TO KEEP THE
BUSINESS OF THE HOUSE REGARDLESS
OF THE CIRCUMSTANCES- I THINK
GOING FORWARD- PANDEMIC OR NOT
WE NEVER KNOW WHAT CHALLENGES
THE LEGISLATURE MIGHT FACE IN.
AND WHY A MEMBER CAN'T BE HERE
FOR SESSION- OR WHAT THE
OPPORTUNITY IS FOR SOMEBODY. TO
COME FORWARD AND MAKE SURE THAT
THERE'S A QUORUM PRESENT. THERE
BEEN NUMEROUS INSTANCES WHERE WE
FOUND OUT THAT A MEMBERS UNABLE
TO CHEER- AS A SENATOR FROM SAN
FRANCISCO JUST SAID. WITH VERY
SHORT NOTICE- IN I DON'T KNOW
WHAT WOULD'VE BEEN ONE AHEAD.
BUT WHAT ELSE WE WOULD HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO DO- WITH THE URGENCY OF
THE BUSINESS TRYING TO GET BILLS
OUT ON TIME- HEAD. OF OUR PRO
TEM NOT BEEN ABLE TO MAKE- A
SUDDEN. ABOUT APPROPRIATE MOVE
ONE EMPHASIZE. THAT THIS. RULE
DOESN'T REMOVE THE RULES
COMMITTEE FROM CONSIDERING
APPOINTMENTS UNDER TYPICAL
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT'S STILL GOING
TO BE DONE. MERELY PROVIDES THE
FLEXIBILITY IN THOSE EXIGENT
URGENT CIRCUMSTANCES FOR THE
PROTEIN TO DO SO WHEN SUCH
SITUATIONS ARISE IN MACON AND
FEASIBLE. THE CONVENE THE RULES
COMMITTEE UNDER SHORT NOTICE SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF MATTER
PRESIDENT. AND I'D URGE AND I
VOTE. ON THESE RULES THANK YOU
THANK YOU SENATOR CORTESE'S
SEEING NO FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. I AM SECRETARY EXCUSE ME
MADAM HOTEL YOU MAY CLOSE. MAN
PRESIDENT THANK YOU AND TO MY
COLLEAGUES THANK YOU FOR YOUR
DISCOURSE AND COMMENTS. I WOULD
MAKE ONLY A COUPLE OF POINTS- I
THINK IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT TO
KNOW AS WE ARE GOING INTO TWO-
TO THE POINT THAT MY COLLEAGUE
FROM STOCKTON MADE. AS WE'RE
GETTING FURTHER INTO THE BUDGET
PROCESS WITH MORE AT STAKE AND
MORE RESOURCES. I THINK IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT THAT THE
CHANGES REFLECTED IN THESE ROLES
ARE GOING TO ALLOW FOR MORE
TRANSPARENCY AND MORE
PARTICIPATION. ON PROPOSITION
TWENTY FIVE WAS PASSED AND THEN
FOLLOWING UP THAT THE SEVENTY
TWO HOUR RULE. IT REALLY JAMMED
THE AMOUNT OF TIME. THAT WE AS A
LEGISLATURE HAD TO BE ABLE TO
HAVE A CONFERENCE COMMITTEE. AND
OF COURSE IN THE LAST TWO YEARS
WE'VE HAD A PANDEMIC. I AND
FEWER ABILITIES TO HAVE THE
EXTENSIVE HEARING PROCESS IN
CONFERENCE COMMITTEE THAT WE
WANT THIS IS AN IMPROVEMENT- LET
ME ASK MY COLLEAGUE AND- I FROM
SANTA CLARITA. MY APOLOGIES-
WITHOUT REFERENCE TO FILE IS.
WHAT WE HAVE AS OUR- IT AT OUR
DISPOSAL TO BE ABLE TO MOVE
SOMETHING QUICKLY SO TO BE ABLE
TO DO THIS IN ADVANCE OF DEEPER
DISCUSSIONS FOR THE BUDGET TO BE
ABLE TO CONTINUE TO APPOINT AS
NEED BE. I APPRECIATE AND I WILL
SAY THE RULES ARE DONE EVERY TWO
YEAR SESSION THE SENATE RULES
HAVE TO BE APPROVED THE JOINT
ROLES ARE DO NOT HAVE TO BE DONE
AS OFTEN BUT THE DESIRE IS TO DO
THAT. AND I THINK IT IS
IMPORTANT WE DO THAT NOW I WILL
ALSO LASTLY SAY- I THINK I'VE
SHOWN THAT I PREFER- THAT
EVERYTHING POSSIBLE GO THROUGH
THE RULES COMMITTEE I'VE SERVED
WITH. A NUMBER OF MEMBERS ON THE
RULES COMMITTEE WHEN I CAME INTO
THE SENATE I WAS ON THE RULES
COMMITTEE WITH MADAM PRESIDENT.
OUR PRESIDING TODAY. AND I'VE
HAD THE PLEASURE TO SERVE WITH
OUR FOUR DIFFERENT VICE CHAIRS
WHICH ARE FROM THE OTHER. PARTY
AND I THINK- IT IS IMPORTANT TO
RESPECT THE RULES AND THE RULES
COMMITTEE. AND BECAUSE COMMENTS
HAVE BEEN MADE ON THE FLOOR I
REALLY THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO
SAY THAT I BELIEVE THOSE THINGS
ARE IMPORTANT I BELIEVE
COLLEGIALITY IS IMPORTANT I
BELIEVE THE RESPECT TO EVERY
MEMBER. ANNA IS IMPORTANT
REGARDLESS OF PARTY. AND SO WE
WILL CONTINUE TO PRACTICE IN
THAT REGARD BUT I WOULD GREATLY
APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT TO GET
THESE JOINT ROLLS PAST. AND ASK
FOR YOUR ARRIVAL. THANK YOU
SENATOR ATKINS BUT SENATOR WILK.
ASK FOR A ROLL CALL VOTE
ABSOLUTELY. MA'AM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN I
ARCHULETA FIVE ADKINS I BASE.
BACKER I FORTUS NOTES BRADFORD I
HAVE A DAUGHTER HI CORTESE FIVE
DALLY. DOT FIVE TORONTO I
EXAMINED EYE LASER EYE
CONSOLIDATES HIGH GROWTH NO
HURTS BERG HI WESA. FIVE HER
TADO I JONES NO CAMCORDER HI
WHERE. I LIVE ON I LIVE ALONE I
REQUIRE I MELINDA'S NO MAN I
NEWMAN I NIELSEN NO A TRIO OF
BOTH. NO PAM HI FORTUNE TINO HI
RALPH I RUBIO FIVE SKINNER.
STERN I AM BERG AND FIVE WE CAN
SKI. I WINNER I WILL KNOW. FIVE
THIRTY NO SEVEN THE MEASURE
PASSES MEMBERS WE NOW NEED TO
APPROVE THE SENATE JOURNAL.
WITHOUT OBJECTION THE SENATE
JOURNALS FOR THE WEEK OF
FEBRUARY TWENTY EIGHTH TO MARCH
THIRD TWENTY TWENTY TWO WILL BE
IMPROVED AND CORRECTED BY THE
MINUTE CLERK. PRIME MEMBERS WE
ARE NOW MOVING ON TO
CONSIDERATION OF THE DAILY FILE
WE'LL START WITH GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTMENTS ITEM ONE THE
SENATOR LAYERED. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- MADAM PRESIDENT AND
MEMBERS FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE IS
THE CONFIRMATION OF NATALIE PALU
K. I. AS SECRETARY OF THE LABOR
AND WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
AGENCY. PRIOR TO THIS ROLE SHE
WAS A SENIOR ADVISER AT JOHN
HOPKINS UNIVERSITY SPENT SEVERAL
YEARS AS A SENIOR ADVISER AT
THE- OF THE US DEPARTMENT OF
LABOR AND IS THE FIRST LATINA
TUBE WITH A POINTED SECRETARY OF
THE CALIFORNIA LABOR AND
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT AGENCY.
SHE WAS APPROVED IN THE RULES
COMMITTEE ON FEBRUARY THIRD ON A
FIVE OH VOTE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I. PHONE. THANK YOU
SENATOR LAYER. BOTH QUESTIONS
AND DEBATE CENTER TORONTO YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT I ALSO RISE IT'S
MY HONOR TO SUPPORT NATALIE
BELUGA AND RECOGNIZE THE
HISTORICAL SIGNIFICANCE OF HER
COMPORTMENT APPOINTMENT AND
CONFIRMATION. AS A PROUD
DAUGHTER GOOGLE I. N. IMMIGRANTS
SHOULD BE THE FIRST LATINA TO
SERVE OUR STATE AS LABOR
SECRETARY SHE HAS SUBSTANTIAL
EXPERIENCE ON LABOR ISSUES FROM
SERVING IN THE ADMISSIBLE BOMB
ADMINISTRATION TO WORK IN
ACADEMIA- SHE SPOKE TO OUR
BUDGETS- SUB FIVE COMMITTEE ON
HIGH ROAD TRAINING AND LABOR
STANDARDS OF- SHE HAD A SPOKE TO
OUR LATINO CAUCUS EXTENSIVELY ON
ALL THESE ISSUES SHE'S WE NEED A
STRONG LEADER FOR WORKERS ACROSS
THE STATE AT THIS TIME. AND I'M
GLAD TO HEAR THAT SHE IS SUCH A
SOCCER SOCCER FAN WELCOME TO
CALIFORNIATHE STATE OF MILLIONS
OF SOCCER FANS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU SENATOR RAZA
MEMBERS FURTHER DISCUSSION AND
DEBATE. SEEING AND HEARING NONE
FROM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN I ARCHULETA I ATKINS
I BASE BACKER HI PORCHES I
BRADFORD I COME BEARING I
PROTESTING I DOLLY. DOT. FIVE
ZERO SEVEN FIVE EGGMAN HI
PLEASE- I CONSOLIDATES OUR
GROWTH I HEARD SPURRED BY
WESTERN. I HER DAUGHTER HI JONES
I CAN LONGER I LAYERED I LABOR I
THE MOON HI WIRE. I MELINDA'S I
MEN I NEWMAN I NIELSEN BY A SHOW
OF BOTH HI CAN I FORCING TINA HI
ROB HI RUBIO. HI SKINNER STERN
HI I'M BURKE ALL RIGHT HI QUITE
HOW SKI FIVE WINNER I WILL HI.
THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO THE
APPOINTMENT IS CONFIRMED MEMBERS
WE'RE MOVING TO ITEM THREE SAID
EARLIER THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MADAM PRESIDENT OF FILE ITEM
NUMBER THREE IS THE CONFIRMATION
OF DOCTOR JOE WE PROFIT AND THE
COAL WHITEMAN TO THE CALIFORNIA
COMMISSION ON THE STATUS OF
WOMEN AND GIRLS DR PROFIT IS
PROFESSOR AND CHAIR OF THE
AMERICAN INDIAN STUDIES
DEPARTMENT AT CSU SAN MARCOS AND
MISS WALKMAN IS THE CHIEF
EXECUTIVE OFFICER OF THE LOS
ANGELES DODGERS FOUNDATION WHICH
MAY NEED TO LEAD TO ANOTHER
SPEECH FROM PEOPLE FROM SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. THESE APPOINTMENTS
WERE APPROVED BY THE RULES
COMMITTEE ON FEBRUARY TWENTY
THIRD ON A FIVE OH VOTE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR RIFLE
THANK YOU CENTER LAYERED MEMBERS
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE SEEING AND
HEARING THAT MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN FIVE
ARCHULETA. HI ATKINS I FACE
BACKER I PORCHES HI BRADFORD I
KERR BY ADAM HI CORTESE I DAILY
. DOT FIVE TORONTO I EXAMINED I
GLAZER HI CONSOLIDATES FIVE
GROWTH I HEARD SPURRED I WAS SO
. I HER DAUGHTER I JONES I CAN
WATER I LAYERED I FLAVOR I LIVE
ALONE I REQUIRE I MELINDA'S FIVE
MIN I NEWMAN I NIELSEN HI I
UNTIL ABOUT FIVE PM HI FOURTEEN
TINA. HI RALPH FIVE RUBIO I
SKINNER STERN HI I'M AMBER HI
FORECASTING I WINNER I WILL HI
THREE SEVEN NINE ZERO THE
APPOINTMENT IS CONFIRMED MEMBERS
WE'RE MOVING ON TO SENATE THIRD
READING WE'RE GOING TO START
WITH ITEM TWELVE SENATOR LEE MON
MAN SECRETARY PLEASE READ SENATE
RESOLUTION SIXTY SIX BY FEDERAL
AMOUNT RELATIVE TO THE
ANNIVERSARY OF THE CALIFORNIA
FAIR PAY ACT CENTER LAMONT THANK
YOU THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
COLLEAGUES S. R. SIXTY SIX
RECOGNIZES JANUARY TWENTY NINTH
AS THE ANNIVERSARY OF THE
CALIFORNIA FAITH CARE ACT. AND
ITS HISTORIC IMPORTANCE TO THE
ADVANCEMENT OF WOMEN'S RIGHTS IN
OUR STATE THE CALIFORNIA FAIR
PAY ACT REQUIRES EQUAL PAY FOR
EMPLOYEES WHO PERFORM
SUBSTANTIALLY SIMILAR WORK AND
HER PROHIBITS AN EQUAL PAY FOR
EMPLOYEES OF DIFFERENT RACES
ETHNICITIES AND GENDERS WHAT
CALIFORNIA HAS THE STRONGEST
EQUAL PAY LAWS IN THE NATION THE
GEEK AT THE PAY GAPS STILL EXIST
WITH WHITE WOMEN EARNING EIGHTY
CENTS ASIAN AMERICAN WOMEN
EARNING SEVENTY FIVE CENTS BLACK
WOMEN EARNING SIXTY CENTS AND
LATINA WOMEN EARNING FORTY THREE
CENTS FOR EVERY DOLLAR A WHITE
MAN EARNS. THE PAY GAP IS NOT
NOT ONLY IMPACTS WOMEN BUT IT
ALSO IMPACTS PEOPLE OF COLOR
ACCORDING TO THE MOST RECENT
ANALYSIS OF PAY DATA CALIFORNIA
WOMEN IN TWENTY TWENTY LOST
FORTY SIX BILLION DOLLARS TO THE
GENDER PAY GAP AND PEOPLE F
COLOR IN THE STATE LOST SIXTY
ONE BILLION DOLLARS. DUE TO THE
RACE PAY GAP. THE WAGE GAP
ACROSS INDUSTRIES OCCUPATIONS
AND EDUCATIONAL. FULL NOT ONLY
ON WOMEN AND PEOPLE OF COLOR BUT
ALSO ON THE FAMILIES THE SUPPORT
AND THE ECONOMY AS A WHOLE. I
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU
THIS YEAR AS WE PURSUE WAYS TO
NARROW THE GENDER AND RACIAL PAY
GAP AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN IPHONE. THANK YOU SIR LOAN
SENATOR PAM. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT- CENTERS I TO- RISE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE- OF S. R.
SIXTY SIX I WANNA THANK MY- GOOD
FRIEND- FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD AND ON BEHALF OF THE
ASIAN PACIFIC ISLANDER
LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS- I REALLY
WANT TO. RECOGNIZE THAT THIS IS
AN EXTREMELY IMPORTANT ISSUE FOR
THE API COMMUNITY WHERE EACH OF
OUR COMMUNITIES AS DIVERSE AND
UNIQUE. ON AVERAGE API WOMEN
MAKE EIGHTY FIVE CENTS FOR EVERY
DOLLAR THAT A WHITE NON HISPANIC
MALE MAKES. HOWEVER SOUTHEAST
ASIAN AND PACIFIC ISLANDER WOMEN
EXPERIENCE EVEN LARGER- WAGE
GAPS FOR EXAMPLE VIETNAMESE
WOMEN EARN AN AVERAGE OF SIXTY
SEVEN CENTS FOR EVERY DOLLAR
PAID TO WHITE NON HISPANIC MALE.
AND BURMESE WOMEN EARN AN
AVERAGE AS LOW AS FIFTY TWO
CENTS. WOMEN ARE THE REASON FOR
SOME OF OUR STATE'S GREATEST
ACCOMPLISHMENTS AND I'M PROUD TO
BE PART OF THE LEGISLATIVE BODY
THAT'S POWERING THE PASSING
DISEMPOWERING ACT. I'VE LOOKED
TO LOOK FORWARD WITH YOU TO
ENSURE THAT EACH WOMAN'S FAIRLY
COMPENSATED AND THAT THE GOALS
OF THE CALIFORNIA PAY ACT ARE
MET. AND AGAIN I WANT IT REALLY
THANK MY GOOD COLLEAGUE- FOR
INTRODUCING THI RESOLUTION AND
HER LEADERSHIP ENSURING EQUAL
PAY FOR EVERYONE. I SUSPECT WE
ASK FOR YOUR I. VOTE ON SR SIXTY
SIX THANK YOU THANK YOU SENATOR
PAN MEMBERS ANY FURTHER.
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING AND
HEARING NONE. CEREMONIES LIKE TO
CLOSE I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND
I HAVE A THANK YOU MEMBERS IS
THERE ANY OBJECTION TO USING A
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. SEEING AND
HEARING NONE ALL EYES THIRTY
SEVEN NO ZERO THE RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
FIFTEEN SENATOR PAM PAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION SEVENTY
FOUR BY SENATOR PAM RELATIVE TO
BLEEDING DISORDERS AWARENESS
MONTH SENATOR PAN THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT SENATORS AS
CHAIR OF THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
HEALTH IT'S MY HONOR TO PRESENT
S. C. R. SEVENTY FOR RECOGNITION
OF MARCH TWENTY TWENTY TWO IS
BLEEDING DISORDER AWARENESS
MONTH. YEAR AFTER YEAR BLEEDING
DISORDERS LIKE HEMOPHILIA VON
WILLEBRAND DISEASE AFFECTS THE
LIVES OF HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
OF CALIFORNIANS. WITHOUT PROPER
TREATMENT PEOPLE WITH THESE RARE
BLEEDING DISORDERS FACE DANGERS
OFTEN PAINFUL BLEEDING EPISODES
THAT CAN DAMAGE THEIR JOINTS AND
THREATEN THEIR HEALTH. EFFECTIVE
TREATMENTS WITH BLOOD CLOTTING
FACTORS CAN SPARE PEOPLE WITH
BLEEDING DISORDERS AND
HOSPITALIZATIONS ARTHRITIS
DISABILITY AND EVEN DEATH.
MEDICAL SCIENCE IS ADVANCING
EVERY SINGLE DAY ALONG FOLKS
WITH BLEEDING DISORDERS TO LEAVE
FULL AND HEALTHY LIFE WITH
APPROPRIATE TREATMENT. DECLARING%
MARCH TWENTY TWENTY TWO IS TO BE
BLEEDING DISORDER AWARENESS
MONTH HELPS EDUCATE THE PUBLIC
ABOUT THESE BLEEDING DISORDERS
OCCUR JUST PEOPLE TO SEEK
TREATMENT IF THEY LIVE WITH ONE
OF THESE CONDITIONS. THIS MONTH
ALSO GIVES US THE OPPORTUNITY TO
HONOR INDIVIDUALS LIKE VAL BIAS
FORMER CEO OF THE NATIONAL
HEMOPHILIA FOUNDATION AND STRONG
ADVOCATE FOR THE COMMUNITY
PLEASE JOIN ME IN RECOGNIZING
MARCH THIS MARCH IS BEING THE
SORT AWARENESS MONTH I EXPECT
THE SP I VOTE ON ITS YOUR
SEVENTY FOUR THANK YOU. THANK
YOU CENTER PANEL MEMBERS
DISCUSSION AND OR DEBATE. SEEING
AND HEARING NONE MEMBERS IS
THERE ANY OBJECTION TO USING
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. SEEING AND
HEARING NONE HIGHS THIRTY SEVEN
NEWS ZERO THE RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED. MEMBERS WE'RE GOING TO
RETURN TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS BUT BEFORE WE DO
OUR- JOURNEY MEMORIES WE AS A
SENATE WOULD LIKE TO WISH
SENATOR BOARD. JUST A VERY HAPPY
BIRTHDAY. ALL RIGHT RESERVED-
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS WE'RE
GOING TO START WITH A SENATOR
MEN AND THEN SENATOR NUMBER. ON
THE SAME ADJOURNED SENATOR MAN.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT.
MEMBERS TODAY I RISE TO ADJOURN
THE MEMORY OF HUNTINGTON BEACH
POLICE OFFICER NICHOLAS BELLA.
ON THE NIGHT OF SATURDAY
FEBRUARY NINETEENTH TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY TWO. AROUND SIX THIRTY PM
A HORRIFYING DISASTER TOOK PLACE
IN MY DISTRICT THAT SHOCKER
ORANGE COUNTY COMMUNITY. OUR
SPON IN A CALL FOR SERVICE A
HUNTINGTON BEACH POLICE
HELICOPTER CRASHED IN THE WATERS
OFF NEWPORT BEACH WITH TWO
PILOTS ON BOARD. INCLUDING
OFFICER BELLA AND IS CO PILOT.
BUT UNFOLDED WAS TRULY
REMARKABLE IN THE WAKE OF SUCH
TRAGEDY. EMERGENCY RESPONDERS
JOINED BY CIVILIANS IN NEARBY
BOATS SWIM TO THE HELICOPTER
RISKING THEIR OWN LIVES TO ACT
QUICKLY AND PULLED THE TWO
OFFICERS FROM THE WRECKAGE.
WHILE ONE OFFICER DID ESCAPE
THAT THE CRASH SADLY OFFICER
NICHOLAS VELLA LOST HIS LIFE. A
HUSBAND A FATHER A PILLAR OF OUR
HUNTINGTON BEACH COMMUNITY
OFFICER VELLA DEDICATED HIS LIFE
AND CAREER TO THE SERVICE OF
OTHERS. AT FORTY FOUR YEARS OLD
HE WAS AT THE HEIGHT OF HIS
CAREER. AND WHAT STRIKES ME MOST
IS HOW I HEAR AGAIN AND AGAIN
HOW OFFICER FELLOW SO GENUINELY
LOVED HIS JOB WAS SO COMMITTED
TO IT. HE DEDICATED EIGHTEEN
YEARS OF PROFESSIONAL SERVICE TO
PROTECTING ORANGE COUNTY.
FOURTEEN YEARS WITH THE
HUNTINGTON BEACH POLICE
DEPARTMENT. BEFORE THAT FOR
YEARS WITH THE LAGUNA BEACH
POLICE DEPARTMENT. OFFICER
RATHER WAS KNOWN TO GO ABOVE AND
BEYOND THE CALL OF DUTY. THOSE
WHO KNEW HIM AND LOVED HIM
CONSIDERED HIM A ROLE MODEL AND
AN EXAMPLE OF HOW TO LEAD IN THE
SERVICE OF OTHERS. ORANGE COUNTY
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WILL
ALWAYS BE GRATEFUL FOR HIS
DEDICATION AND SACRIFICE. I
ASKED THE SENATE JOIN ME TODAY
IN OFFERING OUR MOST SINCERE
CONDOLENCES TO HIS BELOVED WIFE
CHRISTIE. IS TEENAGE DAUGHTER.
IS ADDITIONAL FAMILY MEMBERS.
HIS COLLEAGUES AND FRIENDS I ASK
THAT THIS BODY ADJOURNED TODAY
IN HIS MEMORY. THANK YOU
CENTERMAN CENTER- BURKE. THANK
YOU ADAM PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES
ARISE WITH A HEAVY HEART. TO
JOIN MY COLLEAGUE FROM IRVINE IN
RECOGNIZING THE LIFE. AND LEGACY
OF OFFICER NICHOLAS BELLA. IS A
FOURTEEN YEAR VETERAN OF THE
NEWPORT POLICE DEPARTMENT. AND
ALSO A VETERAN OF THE HUNTING
SIMPLY BEACH POLICE DEPARTMENT.
HE AND HIS FREE TIME SPORT
VARIOUS NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS
AND COMMUNITY GROUPS SUCH AS
OPERATION SURF BAKER TO VEGAS
ADOPTIVE FREEDOM FOUNDATION. AND
THE HEIGHTENED BEACH POLICE
OFFICERS FOUNDATION. I DID NOT
KNOW OSTERVILLE- BUT I KNOW A
NUMBER OF FOLKS WHO DID AND THEY
ALL UNANIMOUSLY. DESCRIBED HIM
AS SELFLESS AND DEDICATED TO
BOTH HIS FAMILY AS WELL AS TO
THE COMMUNITY. AUSUBEL HAD A
TREMENDOUS IMPACT NOT ONLY A
HIKE TO BEACH BUT ALSO
THROUGHOUT SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA-
WE GRIEVE WITH HIS WIFE AND HIS
DAUGHTER HIS WIFE CHRISTI TOWBAR
AND HIS TEENAGE DAUGHTER. I ASK
THAT WE ALL JOINED IN ADJOURNING
IN HIS MEMORY THANK YOU THANK
YOU SENATOR AMBERG PLEASE MAKE
SURE HIS NAME IS BROUGHT FORWARD
SO HE MAY BE PROPERLY
MEMORIALIZED AT CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE. SENATOR OCHO BOKE. I
RISING. TO ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF
SARTAJ SINGH WHO IS A DEAR
RESIDENTS OF SENATE DISTRICT
TWENTY THREE. SO TIRED SHE WAS
AFFECTIONATELY CALLED SEEING BY
HIS FRIENDS AND COLLEAGUES WAS A
BEAUTIFUL SOUL WHO EPITOMIZED
THE AMERICAN DREAM. HE WAS THE
OLDEST OF FOUR CHILDREN IN
PUNJAB INDIA WHERE HE TOOK ON A
FATHER YOU LEAVING THE ROLE FOR
HIS YOUNGER SIBLINGS FROM AN
EARLY AGE. AFTER LEARNING HOW TO
COOK ITALIAN CUISINE IN EUROPE
HE MOVED TO RANCHO CUCAMONGA
WITH A DREAM TO OPEN UP AN
ITALIAN RESTAURANT. DURING HIS
THIRTY YEARS IN THE INDUSTRY FOR
TAJ OPEN MANY SUCCESSFUL
RESTAURANT HE TOOK. ON THE
ADVENTURE OF DABBLING IN
DIFFERENT BUSINESSES AS WELL.
OUTSIDE OF HIS PASSION FOR
COOKING HE WAS ALSO VERY
DEDICATED TO PROMOTING AND
IMPROVING HIS COMMUNITY. HE WAS
ALWAYS THERE TO HELP SUPPORT OR
EVEN BE A SHOULDER TO CRY ON HIS
NUMBER ONE PRIORITY WAS MAKING
PEOPLE FEEL WELCOME TO. SARTAJ
WITH NOT ONLY THE DEFINITION OF
THE AMERICAN DREAM BUT ALSO A
TRUE BEACON OF HOPE FOR OUR
COMMUNITY HE WILL BE DEARLY
MISSED. THANK YOU SENATOR
TROUBLE PLEASE MAKE SURE HIS
NAME IS BROUGHT FORWARD SO HE
MAY BE PROPERLY MEMORIALIZED FOR
THE CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE.
SENATOR WIENER I BELIEVE YOU
HAVE TO PLEASE BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE
READY. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT- COLLEAGUES- I RISE
TODAY TO ASK THAT THE SENATE
ADJOURNED IN MEMORY OF RICHARD
BLUM. THE HUSBAND OF OUR UNITED
STATES SENATOR DIANNE FEINSTEIN.
ON ALSO WELL KNOWN FOR HIS- LONG
TIME EFFORTS TO FIGHT POVERTY.
AND PROMOTE HUMAN RIGHTS FOR
PEOPLE AND THE HIMALAYAS. HE
DIED LAST WEEK AFTER ALONG
FIGHT WITH CANCER. HE WAS EIGHTY
SIX YEARS OLD. RAISED IN SAN
FRANCISCO- DICK GRADUATED FROM
LOWELL HIGH SCHOOL. HE GRADUATED
WITH AN MBA. FROM BERKELEY'S
HAAS SCHOOL OF BUSINESS. HE WAS
CHAIRMAN OF BLOOM CAPITAL
PARTNERS AN EQUITY INVESTMENT
MANAGEMENT FIRM THAT HE FOUNDED
IN NINETEEN SEVENTY FIVE. HE WAS
ALSO A PHILANTHROPIST AND
HUMANITARIAN. HE BECAME KNOWN
FOR HIS WORK AS FOUNDER OF THE
AMERICAN HIMALAYAN FOUNDATION-
AN EFFORT TO BRING SHELTER
SAFETY EDUCATION. HEALTH AN
OPPORTUNITY- TO PEOPLE AND- THAT
AREA OF THE WORLD. ON THE
FOUNDATION HELPED TO DIVERT MORE
THAN TWELVE THOUSAND YOUNG WOMEN
FROM CHILDHOOD SLAVERY AND
PROSTITUTION. HE WAS A LONGTIME
FRIEND OF THE DALAI LAMA AN
HONORARY CONSUL OF NEPAL. HE WAS
ALSO A MEMBER AS YOU KNOW THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA BOARD
OF REGENTS. I WAS CHAIRMAN
EMERITUS OF THE BOARD. UNDER HIS
LEADERSHIP- HE REINED IN UC'S
HIGH SPENDING OFFICE OF THE
PRESIDENT IN THE MID TWO
THOUSANDS. AND HELP BRING IN A
NEW PRESIDENT MARKET OFF. HE
FOUNDED THE BLOOD CENTER FOR
DEVELOPING ECONOMIES OF THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
BERKELEY- WHICH HELPS STUDENTS
LEARN ABOUT FIGHTING POVERTY
AROUND THE WORLD. AND HAS LED TO
THE CREATION OF SIMILAR- CENTERS
AT OTHER UC CAMPUSES. WHICH
SERVES INCUBATORS OF IDEAS FOR
SOCIAL CHANGE. IN ADDITION TO
HIS WIFE OF OVER FORTY YEARS
SENATOR FEINSTEIN. ON. MR BLOOM
IS SURVIVED BY THREE TO THERE'S
MORE FOR MARRIAGE AND SEVEN.
PLEASE JOIN ME AND RETURNING IN
MEMORY OF RICHARD BLUM. THANK
YOU SENATOR WIENER CENTER HURTS
BURKE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH MA'AM
PRESIDENT AND JOIN IN THE
JOURNEY IN THE MEMORY OF
DECLINE. AND TO ADD JUST A
COUPLE OF THOUGHTS TO. WE
EXPRESSED BY MY ESTEEMED
COLLEAGUE FROM SAN FRANCISCO.
YOU KNOW BEING THE HONORARY
CONSUL GENERAL OF NEPAL. WHICH
PROBABLY ONE OF HIS GREATEST
SOURCE OF PRIDE HE LOVE THE AREA
LEFT I GET UP IN THE HIMALAYAS
THEY CALL IT THE MONEY IS OVER
THERE NOT THE HIMALAYAS. AND HE
REALLY WAS AS THE CENTER FOR SAN
FRANCISCO SAID A GREAT FRIEND
OF. AND WE HAD A GREAT
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE DALAI
LAMA. IN A VERY DEEP AND
PERSONAL WAY. I WAS FORTUNATE
ENOUGH WHEN HE- BECAME A MEMBER
OF THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
BOARD OF REGENTS TO SERVE WITH
HIM. AND ALSO THE INTERVIEW WITH
HIM AT THIS TIME. AND FOR MY
FRIENDS WHO SERVED AS CHIEF OF
STAFF AND SECRETARY TO THE-
BOARD OF REGENTS. OVER AND OVER
AGAIN GREAT STORIES OF SOMEONE
WHO- JUST PUT AN UNBELIEVABLE
AMOUNT OF ENERGY DEDICATION WAS
DEEPLY CONCERNED ABOUT. SERVING
UNDERSERVED STUDENTS INCREASING
ENROLLMENT AND REALLY WAS- A
PRIDE OF THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA THIS TIME THERE. ALSO
THE OPTION TO WORK WITH HIM
OVERSEAS. MY DEAR FRIEND MICKEY
KANTOR WHO IS A- FORMER
SECRETARY OF COMMERCE WAS. HIS
CONCILIATORY AND WE WORKED
TOGETHER ON MANY ISSUES AROUND
THE WORLD. BUT I WOULD SAY MOST
IMPORTANTLY WAS DEEP LOVE AFFAIR
WITH HIS WIFE. RELATIONSHIP WAS
NOTHING LESS THAN EXTRAORDINARY
IT'S HARD. IN A PUBLIC CONTEXT
WHERE BOTH PEOPLE HAVE. THAT
LEVEL OF PUBLIC EXPOSURE YOU
REMEMBER WHEN. PRESIDENT OBAMA
WAS SWORN IN THEIR STICKLER I'M
STANDING RIGHT BEHIND HIM
BECAUSE- CENTER FEINSTEIN WAS
THE CHAIR OF THE INAUGURAL
COMMITTEE SAMPLE INNINGS AFTER
EXAMPLE IN THAT CONTEXT. BUT
EVERYTHING I'VE KNOWN ABOUT THEM
. OVER SO MANY YEARS JUST
EXTRAORDINARY TO SEE THE DEEP
LOVE THE DEEP RELATIONSHIP
BETWEEN THE TWO THAT WAS NEVER
IMPEDED. BY THE DIFFICULTIES OF
BEING IN PUBLIC LIFE HE WAS
IMPORTANT TO CONTACT- PUBLIC
VOICE IN CALIFORNIA AN IMPORTANT
VOICE AROUND THE WORLD HE WILL
BE SORELY MISSED BY US AND BY
SENATOR FEINSTEIN ASKED WE
JORDAN'S MEMORY. THANK YOU
SENATOR HERTZBERG CENTER WINNER
CAN YOU MAKE SURE HIS NAME IS
BROUGHT FORWARD FORWARD TO ME P.
PROPERLY MEMORIALIZEDBY THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE. SENATOR
WIENER. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT OF COLORS IT'S WITH
GREAT SADNESS THAT I RISE TO ASK
THAT THE SENATE ADJOURNED IN
MEMORY OF ANSWERS HUMAN A
BELOVED SAN FRANCISCO EDUCATOR
WHO DIED AT THE AGE OF THIRTY-
WHILE THE SENATE AND THE
LEGISLATURE WERE IN RECESS. ARE
BORN AND RAISED IN SAN FRANCISCO
AND- DEDICATED HIS LIFE TO
EDUCATING FUTURE GENERATIONS. HE
WAS A BELOVED EDUCATOR AT
SHERMAN ELEMENTARY SCHOOL IN SAN
FRANCISCO- SCHOOL HE HAD
ATTENDED AS A CHILD. HIS FATHER
AND UNCLE HAD ALSO ATTENDED THAT
SAME- SCHOOL- ANDREW SERVE MANY
DIFFERENT ROLES DURING HIS TIME
IN SHERMAN- FIRST SERVING AS AN
AFTER SCHOOL EDUCATOR- AND EVEN
BECAME A PARA EDUCATOR FOCUSED
ON HELPING CHILDREN WITH SPECIAL
NEEDS. HE'S REMEMBERED AS
SOMEONE WHO TAUGHT FROM THE
HEART HE WAS PATIENT AND KIND
AND ALWAYS A POSITIVE ROLE
MODEL. TRAGICALLY ANDREW WAS
KILLED BY A MOTORIST RIGHT IN
FRONT OF THE SCHOOL WHERE HE
TAUGHT SHERMAN- RATE AS A SCHOOL
DAY WAS GETTING STARTED-I JUST
WANT TO SAY THAT WE HAVE NOT
DONE ENOUGH IN SAN FRANCISCO.
AND THROUGHOUT THE STATE. TO
MAKE A STREETS SAFE. FOR PEOPLE
WHO ARE WALKING. SO MANY
PEDESTRIANS EVERY DAY OR BEING
INJURED AND KILLED. R. AFTER
BEING HIT BY A CAR I'M PUTTING
SO MANY CHILDREN AND IT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE HAVE BECOME
NUMB TO AS A SOCIETY- THAT IT'S
JUST A TIMES ACCEPTED IT THIS IS
JUST THE PRICE THAT WE PAY FOR
LIVING IN A SOCIETY. AND I JUST
WANT TO SAY THAT IT'S NOT A
PRICE THAT WE HAVE TO PAY THERE
IS NOTHING INEVITABLE ABOUT
PEDESTRIANS BEING KILLED ON OUR
STREETS THERE IS NOTHING
INEVITABLE ABOUT THAT THERE ARE
THINGS HAT WE CAN DO TO MAKE
OUR STREETS SAFE FOR PEOPLE WHO
ARE WALKING. AND ANSWERS DEATH
IS JUST ANOTHER TRAGIC REMINDER
THAT WE'VE NOT DONE ENOUGH
THIRTY YEAR OLD PUBLIC SCHOOL
TEACHER HE WAS LITERALLY ABOUT
TO START HIS DAY. EDUCATING OUR
YOUTH AND HE WAS STRUCK DOWN THE
TERRIBLE TRAGEDY FOR THE GERMAN
SCHOOL COMMUNITY- FOR SAN
FRANCISCO. AND COLLEAGUES- I
REQUEST THAT WE DO WHAT IT TAKES
TO MAKE OUR STREETS SAFER- AND I
REQUEST THAT WE ADJOURN IN
MEMORY- BANTER THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SENATOR WIENER PLEASE BRING
HIS MEMORY HIS NAME FORWARD SO
HE MAY BE PROPERLY MEMORIALIZED
BY THE CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE.
MEMBERS IT WAS ALSO BROUGHT TO
MY ATTENTION THAT WE HAD ANOTHER
BIRTHDAY YESTERDAY CENTRE HER
TADO HAD A BIRTHDAY FOR THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE HAPPY
BIRTHDAY CENTER HER TADO. IF
THERE IS NO OTHER BUSINESS
CENTER RECKONS THE BEST IS CLEAR.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
FORGIVE ME FOR MY SLOWNESS
GETTING UP HERE THE PROBLEM THE
NEXT FLOOR SESSION IS SCHEDULED
FOR THURSDAY MARCH TENTH TWENTY
TWENTY TWO AT NINE AM THANK YOU
. THANK YOU MADAM PRO TEM THE
SENATE WILL BE IN RECESS UNTIL
THREE THIRTY AT WHICH TIME THE
ADJOURNMENT MOTION WILL BE MADE
WE WILL RECONVENE THURSDAY AT
NINE AM HAVE A GREAT REST THE
DAY MEMBERS.